I'm Chuck Wolf and I am an Assistant Scout Master with Troop 342 in Raleigh, North Carolina.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scout Master-
Little-known fact in British royal history:
King Richard III ran a camping equipment store-
It was the royal camping equipment store- right
Right there in London,
And every December he would put a big sign in the window that read:
Now is the winter of our discount tents.
Yep, that's all I got.
Hey, this is podcast number 285..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Oh my, let's take a look at the mailbag.
Oh, right over on Amazon
We got a very kind review of my book- So Far, So Good- from Kendall Brown.
He said
I read this when it first came out and I loved it.
I bought two copies, gave one away to a fellow scouter,
the second one to other Assistant Scout Masters in R Troop.
There are so many nuggets of how to run a boy-led troop using the patrol method
and how to handle the quote difficulties-
unquote- that inevitably occur with youth.
Keep up the good work, Clark.
Well, thank you so much, Kendall.
I do so appreciate that
If you haven't seen: So Far, So Good: a new Scout Master story.
it's an easy read and it's just kind of in a storytelling style.
Talks about the patrol method and how you work at it
and how you work with scouts to make it happen.
You can get it on Amazon, obviously,
and you can get an electronic version for your Kindle reader
or any other reader at scoutmastercgcom.
And while I'm on the subject,
if you're a regular reader and listener
and the resources that I've created have helped you,
I'm asking you return the favor
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
The funds we get from backers go to cover the expenses
of producing and publishing everything at scoutmastercgcom
and including this podcast you're listening to right now.
So go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page
and you can choose from a number of options
to support this work.
I'd like to take a moment to personally thank John Clements,
Paul Menina, Kelly Tansy and Gerald Dosh,
who've all become backers since our last podcast.
Once again, go to scoutmastercgcom,
become a backer this week
and I'll be sure to thank you during our next podcast.
If you keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed,
I should say we hit a considerable Facebook milestone this week.
If Facebook, if you're not interested in it. just
this won't take long,
But we got 10,000 likes on Facebook,
So we've got 10,000 people looking in
on scoutmastercgcom on Facebook.
Thanks everybody,
That was a pretty big deal and I really appreciate that.
But anyway, if you keep an eye on the Facebook feed
and our Twitter feed,
you will find out that we have live chat sessions
And usually these are Tuesday and Wednesday mornings
from eight o'clock to around noon time
or a little past Eastern time
And you can check in and there's a lot of folks that do-
we call them our frequent flyers- and they check in
and we just discuss.
It's just kind of hanging out,
And sometimes there are matters of great import
and sometimes it's just kind of hanging out.
So but I wanted to thank Nick Young,
who's an assistant scoutmaster in Southeast Minnesota,
who was on the chat this week,
as was Jeff Bee, who is an assistant scoutmaster in Nebraska,
and Francisco Lea checked in.
He's in Tucson, Arizona,
where he's currently the scoutmaster of Troop 339..
Brad from North Florida, who's a past cubmaster
and now working with his son's second year
Weeblos Den was there,
And Kelly, who's in Iowa, currently the troop committee
chair, and during the chat
she says she's probably going to become a tiger den leader
for her youngest this year.
So being a tiger den leader,
what a great thing to do
and what a great thing for a good experience scouter to do.
You should check that out.
If you're a good experience scouter
and you're not going to too many meetings already,
go to the pack and offer to help them with the tiger den.
So in this week's podcast,
I want to spend some time in Scout Master's ship.
in seven minutes or less,
which is going to be more than seven minutes,
which it almost always is,
because you know I like to talk-
I want to share some thinking about
how we deal with the influences of the broader world,
of our broader culture,
when we're working with our scouts,
and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started.
Shall we?
He's my favorite all time boys scout.
You're my favorite all time boys scout.
You were always on the beat boy, beat boy. yeah,
You were always on the beat boy, beat boy.
I'm hanging in the street boy, street boy.
We were dancing to the beat boy, beat boy. yeah,
Feel my favorite all-time boys now.
He's my favorite all-time boys Scout.
What do we do about the outside influences in the lives of our Scouts?
To begin with, let's figure out what's outside and what's inside.
So for the purposes of this discussion, let's make this very, very simple. okay,
Outside influences on our Scouts are something that's beyond the scope of
our control as Scouts. Inside influences are
something within the scope of our control as Scouts.
So let's take a look at what's outside of our control.
So pick any time in the last century or the century
preceding that, or indeed the one preceding that,
and you'll read about adults working with young people
battling the broader influences, the outside ones,
that they can't control, And confronting something you can't control
feels terrible, doesn't it? I mean, it's just very
oh, it's upsetting and it takes up a lot of energy and a lot of time.
It's it's a kind of silly and it's also really aggravating and frustrating.
There's a lot of bad feeling that comes with it, isn't there?
You have a feeling of helplessness and you just try and
fight against things. I want to suggest a better way
of dealing with these things beyond our control. okay,
Because we're outnumbered, We're outgunned.
Here's how psychologist and social philosopher
BF Skinner put it in his book Walden II, He said each of us has interests
which conflict with the interests of everybody else.
Everybody else we call society. It's a powerful opponent and it almost
always wins. Oh, here and there, an individual prevails
for a while and he gets what he wants. Sometimes he storms the culture of a
society and changes it to his own advantage,
But society wins in the long run, for it has the advantage of numbers and age.
So, while we're on this philosophical plane for a moment, we're all humans,
right, We're all swimming in a sea of influences, Call them what you may.
Some of them are within our control and some of them are outside of our
control, And these influences, for good or ill, have always been with us.
They're a part of what we'll call for the purposes of this discussion, the human
condition. Now, I hear from a lot of people and I
am. one of the common threads that I hear from scouts about
is things like outside influences, like video games and cell phones, and the
level of involvement of the scouts, parents and things that are really not
within the scope of a scouter's control. Now, think about
this, okay, Because before we had cell phones and video
games to contend with, there was TV, and before TV there was radio. and before
radio there was moving pictures. and before moving pictures
there was burlesque shows in vaudeville. and
before burlesque shows in vaudeville there were spicy novels.
and you know that guy Gutenberg, with his movable type, he caused a lot of
trouble. Now I'm not saying that influences that are
outside the scope of our control are are either
insignificant or they're totally objectively good
or bad. You know, we just have to accept the premise
that our scouts are subject to a number of influences beyond the scope of our
control. It's part of the human condition. So what do we do?
Do we just give up or do we go to battle with these influences?
So let's get tie all of this to some very practical things we can apply in our
work as scouts. I think that if we go to battle with the
human condition, it means we're fighting a losing battle. Remember,
society wins in the long run, for it has the advantage of numbers and age.
Now you can look at something like that and you go, oh well, let's just give up.
then You know, we don't, we, there's nothing we can do.
so we'll just give up and let these influences roll over us and roll over
our scouts, and everything will go to hell in a hand basket.
But that's not what I'm saying. If battling the human condition is fighting
a losing battle, that doesn't mean that the only other option
is surrendering. I'm not saying that we're going to surrender,
but we have to get to a point to make some progress.
and when we accept that these influences have always been there and
they will always be there- they simply are what they are-
we're going to start making some progress. In his book
Aids to Scout Mastership, Baden Powell discusses dealing with
these types of broad outside influences. He he talks about things like moving
pictures in almost exactly the same terms that I
hear applied to things like cell phones and the internet today.
But after he kind of examines the corrosive influence of moving pictures
on our youth, he encourages us to replace
those influences with something positive. and he quoted me says:
you can't do this by forbidding or punishment, but by substituting
something at least equally attractive but good in its effects.
And over and over again in his writings Baden Powell talks about
this very simple concept, and you know what it boils down to. it's kind of
trite and you've heard it a thousand times before.
it's better to light a single candle than to curse the darkness. so we don't
give up. We don't let the broader influences of
the human condition just roll over us and say, well,
nothing I can control, oh well, we'll just do it. but we don't go to battle with them
either. What we do, we set up something that, as
Baden Powell said, is equally attractive but good in its effects,
And once I started doing just that, I learned
not to battle with these things anymore and I honestly I don't pay much attention
to them because it's really a waste of my time.
I'm trying to control things I can't control. I'm not going to do that.
What I found is, if I apply my energy in my time
to making sure scouts get the opportunities
to do what scouts do and I make the most of those opportunities,
I don't have to worry about battling outside influences, because I've got
something better. I've got a program of lively
activities at whose center is the scout oath and the scout law and the
development of character and man. it really, really works.
I don't have to forbid my scouts to bring video games and cell phones on
camping trips. I just need to make sure that there's no reason
they would need to have them because they're so engaged and excited
in developing their character and discovering all of this wonderful
stuff about the scout, oath and law through these vibrant,
engaging activities. they don't need a cell phone,
you know I I haven't even thought about my cell phone-
that it shouts down all of these other influences.
Each of our scouts has talents and abilities and each has challenges and
difficulties. The interesting thing is, if we spend
our time focusing on how scouting can have a positive influence
on developing the talents and abilities
the, their challenges and difficulties and the outside influences over which we
have no control and are part of the human condition,
they kind of become irrelevant. So remember we were talking about inside and
outside that stuff, outside our control and inside our control. well,
getting getting our scouts into the scouting environment right,
getting them into the place where we do have some control,
is an incredibly powerful force for good in their lives. The other thing
that you'll see if you read back, you know, like I said, over the last
century of scouting, you will see scouts talking about
the influence of an involvement of scouts families
and how it affects their involvement in scouting. This is also
almost totally beyond the scope of our control of scouts.
We can encourage and incentivize families
to work in a certain way for us. but beyond that,
we can't go into everybody's homes and tell them how to raise their
children. If you think about it, every parent that I've ever known,
myself included, is a good influence in some ways- and I'm not so great- or about
influence in others, and you got to kind of roll with that
and you have to accept the fact that the way parents are
is, for the most part, beyond the scope of your control.
so any so let's buy a show of hands. tell me
who picked their parents. which one who's listening
picked their parents? I don't see any hands. okay,
nobody picks their parents. our scouts didn't choose their parents
and changing how their parents are is certainly beyond the scope of their
control. and if you, if you accept that scouts
are pretty powerless to change their parents and they play the hand that
they're, they're dealt them, we get some clues about how
to work with them individually to help them discover and
realize their potential, no matter what kind of influence their parents are
asserting. and it can be hard work for us to find a way
to make that happen for each individual scout and I've there have been many
times where I've talked with parents, formally or
informally, and I've made some suggestions about how things could go
better for them in the context of how things are going
and scouting. sometimes it means getting more involved,
something more often than not it's kind of like: oh well, back,
often, let him do his thing, and sometimes this works
and sometimes it doesn't- again beyond the scope of my control.
if I spend my time and my energy on things that are wholly within my power-
right, like making sure my scouts get the opportunities to do what scouts do,
and I work at making the most of each of those opportunities,
then I begin to see progress in their lives. I begin to see the scout oath
and law active in their lives and, in the relatively short amount of time
that their lives are within the scope of my control,
I help them learn things that will enable them to navigate that wide world of
influences that are beyond the scope of my control.
so, as I said before, this is- this is a kind of a wordy, complicated way
of saying: hey, you know, instead of cursing in darkness, let's light a candle
here. instead of battling with the human condition,
let's get really good at providing opportunities for our scouts to
live the oath and law and grow in character,
grow in stature as human beings and enable them
to navigate the rest of their lives and the rest of the world
beyond the scope of our control. it works, I got to tell you it works.
if you think that it's going to work in a week and a half,
if you think that it's going to work in a year or even two,
you're probably mistaken. it takes a long time. it takes a lot of patience,
it takes getting a real handle on the principles
of scouting and the principles in the oath and law.
and remember, we're not about controlling
and changing the conduct of our scouts, because if that was our goal,
all we need to do is make a bunch of rules- okay,
and that's the easiest way to control the conduct of
a group of people- set up a bunch of laws and rules that controls their conduct.
but we have a bigger aim, don't we? we have something much bigger than
controlling their conduct, because we understand that their conduct
and the way that they navigate the world is motivated
by their character, by the kind of human being they are.
rather than trying to control their conduct, what we're doing is we're
building their character. rules, control conduct. they do a very good
job of that. but to build character you use principles,
and the principles in the scout oath and law are incredibly strong tools to do
just that.
hey, thanks for listening to this 285th edition of the scout master podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch. read the blog at scoutmastercgcom and, while
you're there, you can subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can experience all the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media. join the now 10 000 folks who
like scoutmaster blog on facebook. tweet along with the chorus of 1,300
tweeters on twitter. pin the pultritudinous pictures we
proffer publicly with 2,300 other prolific pinners on pinterest.
watch us at scoutmastercg on youtube. but look, i understand.
not everybody can face facebook. twitter makes some people
downright bitter. not everybody has an interest in pinterest
and a lot of us don't put the? u in youtube. but that's all right. all you
got to do is zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
i'm available all the time at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
it's c, l, a, r, k, e at scoutmastercgcom. and if email doesn't work for you, if you've
got up on the roof of your scout camp headquarters,
you'll find a big spotlight that projects a special signal up against the
clouds, switching on for a few minutes, and i'll get in touch.
alls i need to do before we go is remind you that the scout master blog and
the scout master podcast are not official publications of anybody in
particular other than myself. they're not endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America or any other scouting organization.
they're not official anything. it's just me trying to lend a hand to my fellow
scouts, talking into this microphone and having a
little bit of fun as we go along. and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, sir robert bedan. pal, sir robert.
good luck to you and good camping, why? thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.